oh I'm playing davo Dabo beat me
yesterday
I had a really sad game against davo
yesterday
so here we go again
um
conflicted while opening let's play
Knight C6 let's mix up the opening
playing something that I almost never
play
this is a nimsovich defense
and I'm gonna play D6
I think the more popular move is D5 so
this is a pretty obscure variation
and there's one point if D5 I play
Knight p8 and then later C6 and try and
um token prod that bites overextended
Pawn
so
yeah we'll see how this goes it's a very
modern setup
using the minor pieces to control the
center rather than my Center Pawns
Bishop E3 I'm not sure if my opponent is
prepared or just kind of playing quickly
playing natural moves
um
I mean nf6 looks playable E5 looks very
thematic
E5 ticks takes
I don't see anything wrong with E5
actually
take 6d5 Knight D4 Bishop B5
yeah because the knight's pinned so it's
not actually helping influence the
center so much
and whenever I want I can take it so I'm
threatening to take and then take
so the main line I was just calculating
is takes takes D5
and then I'm thinking Knight D4
where the Knight supported by the pawn
bishop battery
usually pawns aren't involved in with
batteries but
sometimes when the Bishops align with a
pawn then
Square on the diagonal can be used
um
interesting so White's leaving the
tension
gives me the option of taking
and then there's a messy line takes
takes takes Rook B8
I think that's okay for black
and if takes takes 95 I like the like
the the prospect of this
and there's Bishop B5
okay we're going into this
yeah Bishop B5 I'll have to figure out
what to do like maybe King f8 maybe
bishop D7
not happening
so Bishop E2
if I take the knights
it's nice having the E5 Square
not sure how long it'll last for
consuming Queen E7 here
just reinforcing everything
[Music]
and this Knight wants to develop too
there's also like taking
Bishop F3
like just to start with
I'll start by taking
I'm not seeing too many scenarios where
um the bishop stays
now question night
in Knight F6 or 97 97 is so restricted
906 allows Bishop E5 but I think that's
okay
so it doesn't seem like white wants to
trade off this bishop like this is a
better Bishop
now I can play Knight D7
so even though white has a bishop pair I
have a really strong
grip on the E5 Square
um casting coming
whoa It's Mr Gold is off at 2 am
actually I read that name wrong Mr Gold
is off
to Atia
well thanks for gifting 10 Subs I really
appreciate that
sometimes during these more serious
rapping games I I don't look too much at
chat
sometimes like if there's a longer thing
for my opponent I'll go back and see if
there were questions earlier
there is one comment about Queen H4
which
um I did consider
but usually it's just map with G3 or
Bishop G3
okay let's Castle
idea rookie eight
or maybe the idea is um
like to get the other Rook to eat as
well
I mean the e-files uh only half open
file for black only file without a black
pawn
um Queen H4 still comes to mind but
I mean the Pawn's defended
so I think I'd rather
improve
considering each 16h7
because Queen D2 might be coming
yeah Queen d2's coming I really
shouldn't spend too long here
just trying to get a sense of
like after a queen D2 where would where
do I want my pieces
would maybe be nice to have a pawn and
C5 but I don't want to play C5 and allow
takes I think I'll start with A6 trying
to be flexible preparing B5
[Music]
um
yeah B5 why not
because the C4 Square could be
a potential spot for the Knight
probably don't want to go there too soon
but maybe something I might be six
Knight C4
and yeah I really don't mind if takes
takes
again that would be a probably a
positional mistake for white
and there's real ideas of Knight C4 and
I thought B3 would be a little bit
weakening but
that's probably okay
now what to do with my the rest of my
pieces
I think the knights should just reroute
like yeah it wasn't doing anything on B6
after B3
and maybe I can find a new home on C5
that's a move
I want to play this but then Bishop G5
traps a queen
so I have to be somewhat awake somewhat
careful in Queen E7
like long term maybe like eventually
play F5
I think this position takes a lot of
patience
okay so we got two knights against
bishop and Knight this bishop is a very
passive piece
time-wise I'm not doing that great down
about two minutes
I think some moments I've been
overthinking
but based on the position it looks very
comfortable
this E4 Pawn is backwards basically
means I can't move forward and it can't
be defended by a pawn and it's on the
half open file
so we might see Queen D4
or that move
uh let's start with this
93 may be coming
now Queen H4
just applying pressure got two attackers
now
maybe soon to be a third attacker
Knight D7 will unleash the Rook
um do I want to play F6 I think I do
just ensuring that the knight's not
pinned
looks a little bit weakening
my long-term white is maybe dreaming
about 96 but
I'm very far away from that
I'm not sure what my next move is
like the pieces are
almost at their optimal squares and
maybe I can double up like
yeah double up the Rooks
if ever before and just retreat
I mean before Queen e7's my idea
maybe I have to take seriously
because one of these pawns could be
falling
not yet
yeah thank goodness for this g-pawn if
not for this G Pawn I'd be getting
triple Forks
time is leveling
both below five minutes
realizing this Pawn is pinned to the
queen
F5 is probably too risky but maybe I
should have considered that five the
idea of f4
which I really should have concerned
about five like the more I'm looking at
it
too late now
I could throw in taking
a B4 is a good move
yeah I think I'm losing the pawn
it's interesting though because the
queen gets a little bit sidelined
there's also an idea here like if takes
it's gonna say The Rook can't take
because
E1 would hang
okay probably Knight B6 here preventing
Queen A7 and targeting C4
potential Outpost Square
the other day I was playing a game and I
like casually mentioned the word Outpost
I think there were a few people in chat
that were asking like what is an outpost
um
yeah for any experienced chess player
it's like one of the first
chest terms that you'll learn but
there's usually a square that's defended
by a pawn
and occupied by a knight that can't be
attacked by the opponent Pawn
so in this case these pawns have both
extended Beyond C4
so if I get the Knight to C4 there's
never D3 or B3
to kick it away
I guess when Outpost is like almost
always within the puns territory to
territory too
except this is also an outpost on E5
okay Rook F2
I mean I could play this for safety
maybe I should I'm still thinking about
F4 though
I don't think I can resist
I should say F5
takes
it looks so counter-intuitive because
like I'm I'm pinning my Knights
I'm weakening the whole King's side I
mean White's already doubled up but the
point is
the pawn is pinned and I just want to
play F4 and like gain space
and even if Knight G4 like this Knight's
so well defended other Knight can come
in
and there's also ideas of just just
winning the pawn too
like take and take
except oh the knight's still pinned
oh wait a minute
I miscalculate
I forgot G3
okay G3 is not playing
G3 my original plan was to take and take
but Knight F3 would have been illegal
okay here I can play F4
uh this Knight has one square
and now Knight C4
I gradually dominating
like all areas of the board
Center's nice
kingside is becoming nicer
Bishop B2 is probably coming
hmm
I'm gonna play King G6 so I really don't
care
about the night I mean if takes I take
with pong
I have this move but then G3
let's take with Pawn First
wow
it's a fancy move
very fancy
955 is coming
I have to be careful I know this
opponent is very resourceful
take so if I take and then take on e4
the fascinating line
I also play Knight G4
Knight G4 Knight G4 loses upon
let's play this
thank you Inglot
distraction oh also no thank you in
class
distractions are not welcome at this
time
okay I'm just gonna sack
this is
a practical decision
and I just feel strong
attack is ruling and they G4 is a threat
I basically only watch YouTube but I sub
hear a crime because it's literally the
least I can do I really appreciate that
I also really appreciate this move
so G3 I take
and looks like I'm winning
my winning back material maybe not
it's really close though
wow
it has to calculate
G3 I'll pre-move
okay this should be winning oh the end
game is not
it's actually really crazy I can't trade
into the kingpong ending
or can I
maybe it's playable but this is simpler
because takes takes white would make a
pass Pawn
oh I could have taken no I didn't have
C6
okay
this should be winning now
so I won back to exchange and I'm up two
pawns soon to be three Pawns
just have to watch out for the
Breakthrough
uh let's take your first
and this move
um that's a move
but I'm up four Pawns
should be more than enough even though
this Pawn is reaching the seventh rank
or the fact I'm losing this Pawn
yeah I'm not gonna mess up the end game
like I did yesterday
uh good game
um yeah there is a really crazy line if
you turn off the engine here
I want engine assistance just yet but um
if white took with Pawn I wasn't sure
what's happening
because these squares are both covered
I was going to play Queen G3
I was trying to calculate this position
because white hasn't moved Rook G2
and then yeah I didn't know it was
happening I could take on F1
there's no 93
ah maybe I have this
yeah this is probably good enough and
then like takes
let's see engine
so Rook G2 Rogue F1 King F1
Queen D5
Black's not winning
but Blackstone probably has good chances
people are saying Maiden one was missed
where
I made two blunders this game
yeah Maiden one doesn't was not missed
as far as I can see it was Queen H2 I
mean I was threatening made in one
uh here
but G3 defends with a rook
sometimes that can be overlooked
what to do again